you want the Cowboys to draft offensive
defense
[Music]
you look just like this guy I look like
Tyrod Taylor I'm really tired by Taylor
a little bit yeah hey who's your
favorite team the Giants you know what
you think the Cowboys Giants right with
it's the best rivalry ever oh what you
think of the Cowboys come on man I'm a
Giants all right boys is Cowboys but I
mean they got a decent score I'll show
you a Cowboys fan yeah I'm a Cowboy fan
who's your favorite player in the
Cowboys the quarterback what's his name
Ken how good is he like good bro how do
you think Kent can get better I need to
stop listening to Jerry Jones bro he's
always the one him up I think
I've seen that for real I think we
should blame everything on Kent what's
the first thing you think of when you
think of the Dallas Cowboys thank you
Chuck a little bit because everyone just
talks about how America's team and they
have all this history but they just lose
man who would you be worried about from
the Cowboys if they play the Jets easy
Lamb's a piece he's hard Mike is insane
insane I'm Micah Parsons yeah
who's your favorite person to leave uh
Mike Parsons
this year but what y'all do in the
playoffs though we were further than
y'all we live with a super Cowboys fan
who's your favorite defensive player
he's right here what do you think I
should have been drafted easy number one
was you excited about the pick yeah
y'all just be easy on Daniel Jones man
you're a beast I know it's you I think
he's like Skip Bayless favorite player
yeah he make you nervous nah
y'all had a chance to drive the right
way I know bro a lot of teams had a
chance to draft them but Jerry Jones had
a mission he talked to the owners
well I'm a Giants fan but you're a beast
hey I appreciate that